- So wait, so Ben posted
this photo and said,
"Circumstances shall remain mysterious."
So -
(laughter)
I mean, I live next door to you
and I, like, what's
going on in your house?
- This is Friday night.
Truly.
- Yep. Truly.
(laughter)
- This is Friday night.
I'm not kidding.
We've done it for over a year.
We have a group.
We started movie - a movie Zoom.
Oh my God.
It's a lot to look at.
- Yep.
- This is from what is it? Emile Zola?
- [Ben] The Life of Emile Zola.
- [Kelly] The Life of Emile Zola.
- [Melissa] It's amazing.
We've watched every Best Picture winner
and we started over a year ago.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And by the time we got
to Lawrence of Arabia
we had one of our friends, Steve Mallory,
who's in God's Favorite Idiot.
He showed up, he joined
the group on that one,
'cause it's his favorite movie.
And he showed up in full costume.
- Wow.
- And it's a bunch of actors
and directors and producers.
And literally people were like,
oh, we're doing that? Okay.
And so one by one every -
- [Kelly] It got competitive.
- And now we show up every
Friday on Zoom in full costume.
There's some drinks.
(laughter)
- And then we do a Q & A,
we watch the movie during
the week, we do a Q & A,
and then there's dumb
prizes for whoever wins it.
- I love this. So did
this all start in Zoom?
Like in, in Zoom, in quarantine?
- Yeah.
- And then it, yeah. That's so cool!
- Cause we were like, what do we do?
We hadn't seen anyone.
And we're like, we're going crazy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. So it becomes a
thing where now on Friday
we're like "how do I - I need
to be a bagel for the movie.
(laughter)
And you're like, everybody's like,
how do we make a bagel suit?
- Some have been so
elaborate, like some weeks,
like I went through a period where I was
making really huge things and Ben's like,
we need to be able to sit down.
- For Forrest Gump we were
the box of chocolates.
It was pretty amazing.
- Oh my God!
- [Melissa] But it was bigger.
It was like, I made a box of chocolates
that's the size of that rug
- [Kelly] Y'all are so fun!
- And then two of our heads
came through and then I decorated it all,
But then it was like, oh God,
three hours is a long
time to stand like this.
(laughter)
Like I didn't think it through!
- All I'm feeling is like
your lazy apathetic neighbor.
Like I'm like, by the way,
while you're doing that
I'm just like laying on
my couch, like, so tired.